understated as always thank you thank
you thank you did this come together
obviously I know who you're channeling
who am i channeling look character I am
channeling my character that makes it my
character Elton John and Freddie Mercury
all in one but it's definitely mostly my
character but I do feel like that's hot
I am sweating I think that being on tour
has prepared me for this moment cause we
have done shows in this heat and it's
it's we did a show in New York and it
was 98 degrees outside in the Sun was
honest so that was that was the hottest
I think I will ever be so this this
prepared that's not not too shabby okay
so in the movie they do like a super
speedy baby dance can you show us your
best like version of that as a super
super speedy running for the meeting
that's like the super speedy meeting man
okay my supers beaten man yes a bit the
other birds
yeah just with just with my feathers
they'll they'll handle it for me I'm
good I'm good I'm here only sold out a
couple this movie is basically about a
bunch of unlikely friends that sort of
team up if you had to bring one of these
cast mates
onto on tour with you and team up to do
something who would you pick oh okay I
got a couple of answers I would say cool
lean bouncers in the movie and she's are
my really good friend so I'd love didn't
have her on two of me cuz then it'd be
like we're best friends on to her i love
david dobrik so possibly david dobrik
but then i think it'd be fun to also
have like Nicki Minaj or he might as
well just take her onto her before you
sweat to death see you later thank you
so much
[Music]